[Music]
thank you so much what an honor
my ex-girlfriend that a really weird
fetish she used to like to dress up as
herself with an act like a Raging [ __ ]
all the time
hey guys like impressions like
impressions why guys I'm a realist I
tried to romanticize reality you know
like when life gives you lemons honestly
you found lemons when life gets you down
you know make a comforter but at the
same time I don't deny the beauty in the
world guys because there's so much
beauty cos like life can be so
symmetrical that gives birth to this
almost silent poetry you know like a
hermaphrodite playing the keytar or a
young Amish boy trying to blow out the
lightbulbs on his birthday cake or her a
girl is terrible grammar saying mama you
raised me good and then being pushed on
a well guys people complain about my
show they think I act too thick old or
flamboyant and that makes me so angry
[Applause]
[Music]
your mama's so fat you mother still ugly
- so stupid your mother's breasts sag
with such severity through the late
great surrealist artist Salvador Dali
mistook them for clocks
guys I what I'm doing I don't know uh
we've done a lot of laughing which I
can't thank you enough for what we
haven't done log kind of thinking I like
to do that right now and what better to
stop comic inertia a little bit of
poetic friction I've written some haikus
like whose are Japanese poems consisting
of 17 syllables three lines 575 and I
find them have a certain clearness in
their Cochin see sort of a soundness in
their simplicity if you will so we'll do
right now hopefully is I read these
haikus think for a bit and then we'll go
back to the jokes and they'll have
benefited so uh can I get some mood
lighting please just perfect all right
except get the giggles out and I lose my
head cos my aunt used to say slow and
steady wins the race she died in a fire
old people's skin sags because it is
being pulled towards the underworld
[Music]
pages are blank those in glass houses
shouldn't throw stones or macerate the
day time 15 cents a day you can feed an
African they eat pennies and finally
bono if you want to help poor people
sell your tinted shades you two'll thank
you so much guys I believe in the zodiac
you know I'm a Leo I loved inception but
this is something a little bit uh a
little bit morbid ly ironic my
grandmother she was a cancer and she was
actually killed by a giant crack
this is a song about the idea of irony
so strap in my dog's stomach was very
upset so I put him in the car and we
went to the vet and on our way to the
vet I killed a cat I adopted a child
from overseas to rescue him from child
labor factories and on his very first
birthday we went to build-a-bear
workshop
[Music]
isn't that iro and I see Ino are iro and
I see yes in a water park is burnt to
the ground and a tow truck has broken
down I always used to cry when I laughed
and then I was raped by a clown I was
watching Al Gore on CNN he was talking
about the environment and then out of
boredom my pet polar bear shot himself
[Music]
I dated an animal rights activist one
day she got really pissed because I was
eating a veal that was wrapped in pita
bread pita and I say yes Anaheim a
stand-up comic and I always sit and
slouch and I got my girlfriend pregnant
on my sterile uncle's pull-out couch
ironic iro and I see yes and a Bob
Barker got all of my pets pregnant
[Music]
oh the grandfather had Alzheimer's and
one day we were
[Applause]
you